>>> IT WAS NOT OWEN WILSON OR
VINCE VAUGHN, BUT THERE WAS A
WEDDING CRASHER AT ONE COUPLE'S
NUPTIALS IN HAWAII.
[ BLEEP ].
>> OH!
>> HEY!
[ BLEEP ].
>> HEY.
OH.
>> THE WAVES SO STRONG THAT THEY
WIPED THROUGH THE WEDDING PARTY.
TABLES, DECORATIONS.
FLOWER ARRANGEMENTS, ALL WASHED
UP AND MAKING MY INNER PLANNER
CRUNCH.
THE ONE IMPORTANT THING SAVED,
THE WEDDING CAKE.
LET'S BRING IN THE NEWLYWEDS
DILLON AND RILEY MURPHY WHOSE
WEDDING HAD THIS UNEXPECTED
CRASH.
DILLON AND RILEY, A., CONGRATS,
AND B., WHAT WAS GOING THROUGH
YOUR MIND WITH ALL OF THIS
CAREFUL PLANNING?
>> YEAH.
WELL, SO, WE KNEW THAT THE
WEATHER WAS GOING TO BE A LITTLE
CRAZY BUT WE WERE MAINLY WORRIED
ABOUT HURRICANE DARBY THAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO COME.
THAT WAS THE NEW CONCERN.
WE KNEW THE WAVES WERE UP, WE
LIVE ADD 3,000 FEET ELEVATION.
WE COULD SEE THAT THE WHOLE
COASTLINE WAS COVERED IN
WHITEWASH.
YEAH, ALL DAY LONG, THEY WEREN'T
REALLY REACHING OVER THE WALL.
BUT IN THE VIDEO, YOU CAN SEE,
BASICALLY, IT'S JUST THE
CATERING AREA, THAT BIG WAVE GOT
TO.
SO, WE WERE PRETTY FORTUNATE,
BUT, YEAH, DEFINITELY,
DEFINITELY PICK UP SOME OF THE
EMPTY CATERING TABLES AND THEN
THAT BACKUP BAR.
UNFORTUNATELY, WHAT YOU CAN'T
SEE, ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
VENUE, THERE WAS ABOUT 200
PEOPLE GETTING READY FOR THE
CEREMONY.
THAT WAS RIGHT BEFORE THE
>> ONLY TOOK OUT THE BACKUP BAR,
RIGHT?
>> THANK GOD.
>> IT WAS AMAZING.
>> IT WAS LIKE THE ENTIRETY, BUT
THAT WAS THE BACKUP BAR.
AND THE CATERING TABLES SET UP.
WE DIDN'T HAVE ANY FOOD SET UP
YET.
WE WERE FORTUNATE FOR THAT.
AND OF COURSE, THE CAKE.
IT WAS AMAZING THAT THE CAKE
WASN'T THERE.
>> AND YOU WERE THERE.
THE IMPORTANT THING IS YOU WERE
FINE, RIGHT?
>> YES.
>> HOW MANY PEOPLE TOLD YOU IT'S
GOOD LUCK TO HAVE YOUR WEDDING
WASHED AWAY BY A GIANT WAVE?
>> YEAH, SO OUR OFFICIANT DID AN
AMAZING JOB.
FAMILY AND FRIENDS SPRUNG IN
RIGHT AWAY AND STARTED PICKING
UP TABLES.
THE ONLY THING THAT WENT UNDER
WATER WAS THE GUEST BAR AND
RECEPTION TABLES.
THEY TOOK ALL OF THAT TO THE
OTHER SIDE.
FORTUNATELY, WE WERE ABLE TO
HAVE A PARTY AND STILL ABLE TO
DANCE.
WE WERE DANCING IN THE GRASS.
>> AND I THINK THE ONE THING
THAT WE HAD FLOODED WAS OUR
DANCE FLOOR.
NOBODY SEEMED TO MIND.
WE HAD A REALLY FUN PARTY.
IT DIDN'T STOP THE PARTY ONE
BIT.
IT WAS A REALLY GOOD UNION OF
PEOPLE COMING TOGETHER AND THIS
WASN'T WASHED AWAY.
OR THE PEOPLE.
SO IT WAS PRETTY BEAUTIFUL TO
WASH.
>> IT IS AMAZING.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING YOU'LL
EVER FORGET THIS HAS HAPPENED.
MOST IMPORTANTLY, WERE YOU
ANYWHERE NEAR THIS WHEN THIS
HAPPENED?
WAS YOUR DRESS OKAY?
>> MY DRESS WAS OKAY.
MY BRIDESMAIDS AND I HAD JUST
ARRIVED.
I SAND OUR BRIDEMADS WERE HIDING
AND THEN I WAS FAR FROM THE
WAVES.
I MISSED THE INITIAL WAVES.
I LOOKED OUT AND SAW THE ENTIRE
DANCE FLOOR SUBMERGED.
I SAW ALL OF OUR BUD VASES AND
EVERYTHING KNOCK AED OVER.
AND AT FIRST, IT WAS OH, MY
GOODNESS WHAT A DISASTER BUT IT
TURNED OUT TO BE REALLY GOOD
UNION.
>> YEAH, TO KIND OF GAUGE WHAT
HAPPENED, WE LOOKED AT IT
THINKING OKAY, IT'S BASICALLY
THIS LITTLE AREA THAT GOT TAKEN
OUT, WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE,
THE CEREMONY IS ON THE OTHER
SIDE, OUR COORDINATOR AND THE
WHOLE EVENT SPRUNG INTO ACTION
WITH A LOT OF OUR FAMILY AND
FRIENDS.
AND OUR AMAZING DEEJAY, DEEJAY
TIGER WHO WAS ABLE TO KEEP THE
PARTY GOING.
>> YES.
HE KEPT GOING.
>> IT WAS SO FUN.
>> WE'RE REALLY LUCKY FOR ALL OF
OUR FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
>> LOOK, EXPERIENCE WEDDINGS ARE
THE THING RIGHT NOW.
SO, YOU REALLY HAVE DONE IT THE
RIGHT WAY.
DILLON AND RILEY MURPHY, THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING, YOU'RE
HAPPY, YOU'RE SMILING, YOU'RE
WELL.
IT WAS AN EVENT YOU'LL NEVER
FORGET.
WE WISH YOU A LIFETIME OF MOSTLY
DRY HAPPINESS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU GUYS AND DEEJAY TIGER.